hello
my name is kalina filifuk and i work for
the university of warsaw in poland at
the faculty of mathematics informatics
and mechanics
this presentation is done jointly with
dr angie kasilovsky from the same
faculty
during my presentation i will be
discussing some aspects of teaching
analysis with mathematica and share our
experience
we think that this might be interesting
to people from other universities
who already have a plan to create
similar courses
right now especially in our current
pandemic situation
many universities revise their courses
consider how to include
more computations in any computer
algebra
uh system um in their
courses and so our observations might be
helpful
as also a lot of free resources examples
recordings on the internet
for instance at world from you but still
not everything can be adapted for a
concrete university syllabus
and a lot should be done from scratch
firstly first let me very briefly
describe
what kind of courses we teach we have
been given tutorials
for the course of analysis of computer
science students and for mathematics
students for several years
and augmented as a standard course of
analysis with computations in
mathematics especially for computer
science students
moreover we have written a two volume
book
entitled um analysis with mathematica
published by the greater
the first two volume appeared last year
and the second volume is to appear by
the end of
this year and can be pre-ordered on
amazon or publishers website
so you will see the links at the end of
the presentation
uh the book is with a lot of examples
based on our experience and it contains
the necessary
theoretical knowledge
and those examples are in turn taken
from our faculty
lecture notes so we actually included
some of the examples from these books
into this
presentation a typical mathematics
course at the university of warsaw
consists of
lectures at which the theory is taught
and of accompanying problem classes or
tutorials
at the university of warsaw students who
enroll into analysis courses
which are separate actually for
mathematics and computer science
students
are divided into groups of about 20
students each for tutorials
the course of analysis for computer
science students
lasts for one year while for mathematics
students
the course lasts for two years the
course for computer science students is
of course easier
but it's more than the standard calculus
course and students
are required to and to prove statements
and to solve a non-standard exercises
in general students can use any
recommended book on real analysis
or black sheet nodes and
are only required to know the basics of
the ball from programming language
although we have an online course
dedicated to learning the world from
programming language it's not necessary
to take it
before enrolling into the analysis
course after taking the analysis course
students might choose a differential
geometry course about curves and
surfaces which is also done with
mathematica
many mathematics students enroll into
this course
there are also some more advanced and
specialized courses like differential
equations with applications and elliptic
functions which are done with some
use of mathematica one observation that
we have noticed
is that the computer science students in
comparison with mathematics students
learn the world from a programming
language very fast
they are more eager to experiment
programming in mathematica is easier for
computer science students but more
difficult for
mathematics students
so we try to choose problems for our
classes in which mathematica
could be genuinely useful this means
the students do not only apply some
standard algorithm or plotted graph
but they're required to think and to
come up with some mathematical
mathematical idea sometimes this idea
is a guess inspired by mathematical
calculation
or a visual representation of the
problems sometimes mathematica can
only verify these guess in special cases
and sometimes
it can prove its correctness in full
generality
in all such cases we normally still want
to obtain
a rigorous mathematical proof when using
a computer program as an aid
in mathematics it's it's it's very
important to understand
what such programs are suited to and
what
they're not and also what kind of
problems
including correct answers one can run
into
one more observation is that computer
science students
often rely on mathematica and
have difficulty in interpreting the
results
i would like to mention that due to the
current pandemic situation
almost all teaching in many countries
has gone online
also in the coming winter term many
people
think what the future of education will
look like
mathematically combined with video
conferencing software such as google me
zoom skype or any other which allows
to share the screen it's a perfect
replacement for the blackboard
it can be used in both online and
blended learning modes
when we teach online or in class we can
write show pictures and give more
educational material for instance
demonstrations in mathematica to
students
which is very convenient the students
can see
the screen of the lecturer and also
experiment later on their own
another observation that we have is that
now students
seem to be much more interested in using
mathematical maybe
due to the fact that it's more difficult
to to meet and study in small groups
and in person and so students are
more eager to experiment on their own
in this presentation we will present
some examples
of uh analysis of problems
um taken from our books where
mathematica can be used
effectively as an aid in solving
mathematical problems or at least
inspire
the idea of a solution we believe that
skills
um say computational thinking acquired
during the course of analysis can be
applied to solving more complicated
mathematical
research problems later on
so let us have a look at examples i
shall present them
from a very uh kind of didactic and
pedagogical point of view
maybe those examples are very elementary
for experts in mathematica
but we hope that they will be
interesting to educators
so the first example that we have
um is about inverse of
function of the hyperbolic sign the
reason why we chose this example is that
we want to show how
students would be required to think and
learn
about inverse functions this example
also demonstrates
clearly why we should not always rely on
mathematica's output
and we shall show how we can verify the
answer
let us consider the hyperbolic
trigonometric functions
which are in mathematics are of course
defined and building as cinch and course
since in this example we do not want to
use mathematics building
knowledge about these functions let us
pretend
that we ask students to define their own
functions
so this step is usually done very
quickly
many students might then naively try to
use the building inverse function
so unfortunately in this example the
function inverse function doesn't work
correctly
in mathematical 12 1 it chooses
incorrect branch of the function
it can clearly be seen that
this function doesn't take real values
at this step we observe that
many students might continue to work
with this incorrect answer
further without paying attention to the
message
just as a remark for mathematical
developers it's it appears that this
version of mathematica doesn't allow to
specify the domain over which
inverse function should be considered
next when we draw attention of the
students to this problem
of the incorrect branch of the function
we would normally
ask them to obtain the correct answer
and verify it
we might ask whether the function is
invertible
and then compute the derivative of its
inverse
to show that the function sinch is
invertible
we need to show that uh equation
uh sinch of x is equal to y has at most
one solution
in fact we will show that it has exactly
one solution for every real one
this equation is can be easily solved by
hand
just to using the substitution
exponential of x is equal to t
and so whenever the resulting quadratic
equation so at this steps the students
will verify both in mathematics and by
hand
that everything agrees this means that
the inverse function of cinch is
uh correct and we can now find its
derivative um directly
we would then normally reflect and think
how we can improve our reasoning
we notice that the weakness of this
approach is that it requires
explicitly solving the equation f of x
is equal to y for x
in general this can be very hard
and or maybe sometimes even impossible
to do in explicit form however
we do not need to solve the equation to
prove the existence
of an inverse function or
even to find a formula for it
since the function
is defined in an interval we only need
to show that it is strictly monotone
we note also that the image of cinch is
the whole real line so since the
derivative
uh is positive everywhere
um the function sinch has
an inverse function defined on the whole
r
we can now find uh the derivative
using the well-known formula since the
derivative of cinch is clearly course
uh so this can be written as force
uh just uh the the last formula on this
slide
this is indeed the solution of the
problem
but um it's not given in a very
convenient
form so we can
make use of the easily proved identity
um and since cos takes only positive
values
we can take the positive square root
so finally spending quite a lot of time
on this illustrative example
will allow students to verify everything
by differentiating
the mathematica's building function
exchange so students learn a lot of
theory along the way
and learn how to interpret and verify
the computations
another example is from the theory of
functions of many variables
at the beginning the students learned
the properties of the euclidean space
iron and suppose that they are
asked to determine whether the following
assets
uh whether the foreign service bounded
or not
this looks a little bit scary and so
students will normally try to use
computer first
they're usually very happy once they
discover the easy answer without it
so let us go through this example
note that since there is no restriction
on
on the variable that the set is
unbounded
unless it is empty so we need
to find it just one solution to prove
that it is not
empty we can use the building function a
find
instance find instance found a rather
complicated route
but that is all we need if we use a
computer
asking the students to guess a simpler
solution
and possibly moving uh giving some more
hints
we can actually find the following
uh solution so we draw attention of
students to the fact that
we need first um
carefully think about the problem and
try to analyze it
without a computer and the next
example is to find the local extrema of
the function of three
uh variables the
computations by hand are standard but
quite long and tedious um and we think
that doing such an example on a computer
step by step
helps remembering the necessary steps
that should be done to get a solution
we uh remarked that during exams
at our university the students are not
allowed to use mathematica
so learning the algorithm in this way
will help them solve a similar problem
by hand
first we find the critical points we
next
compute the hessian matrices
we can compute the eigenvalues of these
hessian matrices
by means of the function eigenvalues but
mathematica has a function positive
definite matrix q
which makes everything even simpler
this tells us that the second and
the third points are local maximum but
the first case has to be decided
separately
let us have a look at the eigenvalues
there are
one positive and two negative
eigenvalues so the critical point is
neither local minimum nor local maximum
we could also have checked this by
by using the function indefinite matrix
cube
so solving such algorithmic problems
with computer
has advantages as well
so i hope that my discussion today on
some pedagogical aspects of teaching
analysis with mathematical will be very
useful for
educators this approach develops
um computational thinking
in students and i personally think that
it is very important
if you would like to see some more
examples
of from analysis with mathematical
books and possibly use them
in your courses please consult
those please see those web pages
the links uh for the two volumes are
given in this presentation
i thank you very much for your attention
hello are there any questions
i'm just interested to know um
if if you um work at the university
whether
anyone has some experience in
[Music]
in having kind of analysis or any other
subject
uh classes with mathematica
maybe you'll have to unmute your
microphone because i don't hear anyone
oh i'm just addressing anyone
um okay i'm looking at the chat right
now
um if you use mma
online for online courses well actually
we haven't done yet so but but uh
since the next term would be um
online so probably we would have to use
some some elements of of this um
in our online courses next terms
so um what about teaching analysis at
other universities
anyone tried to use mathematical with
teaching analysis
okay i have from the child i have chosen
medical analysis using
python i've not yet taught to use in
mathematica i don't know
[Music]
so um the way we we use it is is just
we have um so our local lecture notes
with a lot of examples and we try to use
mathematica just in those examples
where we can use
of course if some some problem is
theoretical then we will not be able to
uh to use uh miss magikarp
but this is trying to to go beyond
beyond
just plotting the graph or showing
some some some i don't know
plot or just some simple computation so
we
we try to make people think about this
so i'm just not sure
why i do not hear anyone um
because i can read the chat but i don't
hear anyone yeah um
looks like craig has a question
hello
hey guys can you hear me yeah
yes i can hear you um
my name is vitaly khoraf and um
yeah hey we already chatted a little bit
uh galina very nice talk thank you so
much
i have a question maybe i have missed it
because
my connection was a little bit shaky for
how long you already teaching this
course
uh and more so so
this depends on
on my teaching load so so we started
to teach this a long time ago but but
it's not
a year so so we have been developing
this for
a couple of years but but not
consecutively
i see so but you say a long time ago
on and off but you mean like what one
year or five years i don't
know it's it's like maybe five or six
years we
tried once to organize some kind of even
event
also with the polish company gambit kind
of
to promote this mathematical so this
gambit is a local distributor
uh so trying to promote kind of
mathematic car and
everything but but uh yeah so somehow
everything will be faded after that
i see i see and uh
well it depends on the course so if we
are speaking about differential
geometries and it lasts
like half a year if we are speaking
about mathematical analysis for
students uh so this might be if students
for informatics
than it is uh one year uh
courses if we're speaking about
mathematics students then it is a
two-year course if we speak about
internet course kind of on on basics of
mathematics and it is again
um uh half year but but it's it's
repeated
sometimes even twice a year so
it really depends okay
god all right
questions thank you so much
thank you
are there any other questions or maybe
remarks because i'm really
kind of curious how how other people
use mathematica in in online in general
in teaching
either online or face-to-face
so i just don't see any comments
or
raised tents galena you mentioned that
this was for
computer science students yeah
how how did you find oftentimes computer
science
uh students aren't necessarily the top
mathematica or excuse me
mathematics um students that comprehend
mathematics well
how did you find that your course has
benefited computer science students in
learning and understanding maths more
so uh so thank you very much for this
question actually
it's it's a very interesting observation
uh that
we had so if we teach uh mathematical
for computer science students
then uh computer science students learn
just programming language and everything
very quickly but but they have
difficulty in
interpreting the results like in like
mathematicians
uh if we on the other way around if we
teach
mathematics students um
and try to to to to give
them the basics of mathematical language
and everything but they're a little bit
not so quick with uh maybe learning it
um but but they are better in
understanding how to interpret
some results and how to like do a little
bit more steps so if for instance
suppose the problem requires first um
first one step doing something in
mathematica maybe plotting or something
a little bit thinking
than doing some something else so so in
this
kind of many-step solution um
mathematics students seem to be a little
bit better
and interpretation for um
computer science students a little bit
um um
worse and and also so um computer
science
students have their program and and
actually
we have like extra uh classes
for them so so first they just to go
through this
set program curriculum for them um
and in general it it's only
um so this course
is kind of optional for them uh some
some parts of computer
science students just learn mathematics
according to curriculum
and some students uh join our class
and they have additional time uh to
learn mathematica and
to to use it in um in doing the
problems as as as the rest of of the
students is this help
so this is the way how it works at the
university of also
so did the course include both
computer science and mathematics
students in the same
course you paired them up so that the
computer science students
gained from mathematics students
comprehension and mathematics students
gained
from the computer science students
ability to
code and um and um
no no no no no they uh mathematics and
computer science students
go have different curricula and they're
never mixed
in in all classes okay
thank you thank you
again have you ever tried to uh
is
so the voice was not very clear but
but i think um maybe i missed some some
some part
of the question uh but if i understood
correctly
you're asking about how was i trying to
whether our course is kind of
transformable to other universities is
it correct yeah
yes absolutely yeah so uh so so actually
we have written a book
because uh so this is the the the book
which
uh book with um
uh just uh six uh uh chapters in
in one and uh was it five or six
chapters in the other one
so and it goes just uh along the usual
course of analysis say
starting with sets then um
sequences series well i don't know
functions of one variables functions of
two variables
minimum maximum and so on so so forth so
so the only
kind of with everything that
we we teach some some uh theoretical
material
and we explain how to do some examples
in mathematica and how how we um
yeah to try to do this so we never tried
to to get in contact into some
with some other university but but but
actually our book
is is just for um
uh well just in attempt to reach out
a little bit outside of our investment
and try to
uh to show what we are doing and maybe
some some other people from other
investors would be interested
in general i'm interested in kind of
this
um um in general developing
maybe either curriculum or something uh
for like teaching analysis and some some
courses but but
um maybe one of the problems is that at
each university
um everyone has has its own curriculum
so
on one book on the one hand the book is
kind of transferable so
anyone can take it and use it to
use the chapters but on the other hand
we haven't yet tried to reach out to
some particular university and try to
do the course for them
but it would be a very interesting
experience of course
so um i think um
[Music]
this is
[Music]
it's packaged um a mooc um
yeah yeah so i had a look at them but
the problem is that
some of the um some of the examples
of problems a little bit too elementary
for for our students
yeah yeah i understand that i was just
trying cosmetic students
it's not very much suitable so um
it's more question how how you use
mathematica
for educating like analysis not not a
calculus but but
kind of analysis where you need a little
bit more kind of
to think
you